What inspires me
making a difference in the world,
leaving a legacy or making a difference,
having an impact on the lives of other
people and feeling like,
Hey,
my life has been worthwhile.
I did have some modest impact on,
on the people I encountered in this
world.
And uh,
and leading a life of integrity,
of being true to what I believe in
without compromising that in order to
get ahead.
I look for lessons closest to the people
closest to me from my wife who is my
partner,
if you will.
And uh,
from other leaders who might have known
and worked with.
I have a men's group,
but I learned a lot from them and a
couples group,
but we've been together both them for
more than 20 years.
Uh,
and so I certainly learned a lot,
uh,
and also going back to great books and
learning what others have learned over
time,
but how do we bring that forward into a
current day context and watching what
other leaders are doing and try to learn
from them?
No.
All my life,
I've been interested in leaders in part
that was imprinted on me by my father
who thought he should have been a leader
and never was.
And so from a very early age I was
reading books on great leaders have,
you know,
people like Abraham Lincoln,
just a wide range of leaders.
Everything I could get my hands on is a
79 year old boy.
Teaching takes many forms.
I don't know if you want to stay with
teaching leadership.
Certainly we have people teaching is
great things in many,
many,
many forms.
But this is leadership I think has been
under appreciated as an area of academic
concentration.
I think we've been too concentrated on
financial management and not enough on
helping people become better leaders and
creating an environment in which they
could throughout their lifetime and
teach.
Learning them,
teaching them how to learn throughout
their lifetimes to take on more
opportunities and to lead.
So there,
I think it's been a real vacuum and the
teaching of leadership in academic
institutions and I think corporations
have looked at it too much as
socialization to company.
No.